quand quelqu'un me sous-estime,
j'aime apprendre à le connaître et
avoir une conversation avec moi
pour comprendre que c'est je veux dire, je
pense que la question la plus facile à poser
est qu'est-ce qu'elle fait quel est ton talent
tu sais
[Musique]
quand j'étais  environ 13 ans j'ai
regardé ma meilleure amie et l'émission
le monde réel venait de sortir
et alors je lui ai dit oh mon Dieu c'est
ce que je veux faire
je veux être dans une émission de téléréalité
[Musique]
je veux dire je pense  que de moi en grandissant
et en voyant simplement comment mon père et ses
parents et tout le monde
se soutenaient quoi qu'il arrive et
ils étaient juste une
famille très forte et cela s'est
totalement répercuté sur notre génération
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
we'  J'ai toujours été une famille proche, mais je
pense qu'avec tout ce que nous traversons, cela
nous rapproche de plus en plus
parce que nous sommes comme si nous étions les seuls
à
vraiment comprendre ce que c'est, je veux dire
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
Je pense que vous savez que les gens supposent que
les filles d'Hollywood,
vous savez, tout ce que nous faisons, c'est faire du shopping toute la journée et faire la
fête et aller dans toutes ces
boîtes de nuit fabuleuses et tout,
mais je pense qu'ils ont tellement
tort que je suis juste excité  pour que les gens
sachent qui nous sommes vraiment
[Musique]
il est très privé même s'il est dans
le business
et je suis très ouvert et donc il
m'a vraiment appris
à devenir un peu plus privé
et j'ai enseigné  lui comment être un
peu plus ouvert
et ça marche vraiment pour nous
[Musique]
j'espère qu'ils apprendront à
comprendre qu'ils peuvent vraiment faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent
et qu'ils doivent toujours être gentils
[Musique]
je veux dire je suis définitivement  Évidemment, j'ai fait
ma juste part d'erreurs comme tout le
monde, mais j'espère
ne jamais répéter ces erreurs et
apprendre simplement de ce que j'ai fait, donc si les gens, les
jeunes filles ou les enfants peuvent admirer
quelqu'un qui travaille très dur et
se concentre sur vraiment  ce que je veux et fait en sorte que
cela se produise alors
vous savez que j'espère que cela les inspire
[Musique]
quelle est votre réponse je suppose que les gens
disent bien pourquoi voulez-vous partager
des selfies nus et pourquoi voulez-vous
tout mettre là-bas parce que je  je me sens bien
dans ma peau euh
je pense qu'ils sont définitivement
à vous savez après avoir eu un enfant maintenant
après avoir eu deux enfants
il y a un sentiment que je veux dire j'ai perdu 70
[Musique]
livres
[Applaudissements]
je '  j'aimerais dire kim je t'aime merci tu
m'as
littéralement sauvé la vie et je n'oublierai jamais
ce que tu as fait non seulement pour
moi mais pour ma famille
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je veux juste  remercier le président
d'avoir vraiment défendu ce problème
et de voir la compassion qu'il a eue
pour la justice pénale
a été vraiment remarquable
[Musique] [
Musique]
elle avait les pilules dans la main, vous savez
où vous prenez les pilules
et si vous les prenez  wrap
[Music]
juste je n'aime pas les étiquettes je pense juste que je
fais ce qui me rend heureuse
et je veux que les femmes aient confiance en elles